- [Instructor] Let's talk
a little bit about magnets
and magnetic fields and right
over here we have a picture
of what today we would call a magnet
where we have these metal
nails all being attracted
to the stone and the stone,
the modern name for it is magnetite,
and human beings have known
about magnetite for thousands of years
in fact the name comes
from Ancient Greece,
there was the Magnetes people
who settled actually areas
that are often talked
about in the origin of the name magnet,
which are now referred to as Magnesia,
and depending on the
historical count you see
it was one of those Magnesia's
where the Ancient Greeks
were able to find a lot
of what we would call magnetite,
and actually the element
magnesium which is not related
to magnetite was also found in that area,
which is where it got its name.
But it wasn't just some interesting thing
that would attract metal,
and then they also obviously
observed other properties
that if you had two pieces
of magnetized magnetite
it actually turns out that not
all magnetite is magnetized,
something interesting has
to happen to it we believe
it's actually lightning strikes
that magnetizes it naturally,
that the orientation matters,
if you're in one orientation
they might attract each other.
And then if you're in another
orientation if you were
to spin this one around
they might actually repel each other.
And this notion of the orientation
that there might be some
polarity made it more than just
an interesting thing to observe,
an Ancient Han China
roughly 2000 years ago
they invented the first
compass, where they realized
that if you took some magnetized magnetite
which the historical
name for it a lodestone,
and you allow it to freely move
and you could do that by
either hanging it from a string
or have it float on some
still water say in bucket,
that it will consistently orient itself,
so that it points in the same direction.
And so you can use that
for things like navigation
which the Chinese did
roughly a 1000 years ago,
and that helped us realize
that the Earth itself is acting
as a magnet,
and just like a small magnet
has different sides to it,
the Earth does too and
that's where the convention
for a North and South Pole
of a magnet came from.
But there's probably a
question in your mind
from the first time that
you noticed a magnet.
If you have some piece of metal out here,
that's not touching the magnet
and in a future video we can even talk
what touching even means at
a microphone scopic level,
but if you have a nail out
here that's not touching it,
but there's some force that's acting
at a distance on that nail,
how does that nail know to be
pulled towards that magnet?
It doesn't have eyes,
it doesn't have ears,
it doesn't say that there's a magnet
there I better somehow
move myself towards it.
There's something about that region
of space that is
interacting with that nail.
Or if you think about magnets,
how does it know the orientation
of the other magnet to
either be attracted to it
or repel it?
How does it even know that
other magnet is there?
And that's where the concept
of a magnetic field is useful.
And this was introduced by Michael Faraday
in the 19th century,
as a way of at least thinking
about giving us a framework
for this force at a distance.
It doesn't exactly tell us what it is,
but it does gives us a way
of predicting and thinking
about what is happening.
And one way to visualize a magnetic field,
is to take a bar magnet or I
could even say a bar lodestone,
and put it underneath a piece of paper,
and then putting metal
filings on top of that piece
of paper, and you will
see something like this,
in fact I encourage you to do
this to observe this yourself,
and you see what look like lines
that are essentially connecting the North
and South Poles like that.
And this notion of field lines we can draw
it a little bit clearer
in something like this,
was introduced by Michael
Faraday and he says okay
there's this thing called a field,
that tells us for every point
in space around the magnet,
what it would do to
something that is interactive
with the magnet another magnet
or maybe a piece of metal,
so for example, if you were to
put a small bar magnet right
over here, the North side
is going to be repelled
from the North side of
this bigger bar magnet,
and the South side is going
to be attracted to it,
and so what you could do is
you could put a freely moving,
magnet or you could put a compass,
to actually see what the orientation is
which direction will accomplish point,
and it will point in the
direction of these field lines,
and if you were to put it over here,
it would orient this way if
you allow it to freely move,
where this is the Northern end,
and this is the Southern end,
and if you were to put it here
and you were allow it to
freely move let's say as part
of a compass,
and if this is the Northern end
and this is the Southern end,
it would orient like that.
And so that helps you draw the field lines
and also know the direction.
And just by convention the
direction is where coming
from the North Pole into the South Pole.
And what Faraday said is not only does
this tell you the direction
of the magnetic field,
it tells you the magnitude based
on the density of these field lines.
So for example, the magnetic
field is stronger here,
where in that unit area
that I just made you have
very dense field lines,
while it would be weaker right over here,
I have fewer field lines.
Now another amazing thing about magnets
and their polarity
that people have noticed
since ancient times is,
you would think at least initially,
that if this has a North
Pole and a South Pole,
then maybe you could
separate these two things,
maybe if you were to break this in half,
then you could have a
pure North Pole magnet
and you could have a
pure South Pole magnet,
but that's not what happens
when you break this in half,
instead you have two magnets
each with their own North
and South Poles, and then
you can keep doing this,
and early scientists just
kept doing it and said
there might not be any limit
to how much you can cut this obviously,
when you keep cutting
and cannot cut any more
while retaining the properties
of the magnetite you're getting
down to the molecular level,
and in future videos
we'll think about how even
at a molecular level you can
still have a little tiny magnet
that has a polarity to it.
Now another really interesting thing
about magnets is this connection
between magnetism and electricity.
People have also observed
that if you took a current carrying wire
and the current is going from the positive
to the negative end so it
is going in this direction,
and if you make it go
through a piece of paper
that has metal filings,
it looks like field
lines are forming here,
magnetic field lines, it
turns out it does interact
with the types of things
that tend to interact
it will interact with magnets
and so this is a magnetic
field that is being formed
by an electrical current,
and so that was the major
clue that the phenomena
of electricity and magnetism
are in fact related,
and this relationship is what allows us
to do things like have electric motors,
or generate electricity
from wind or water turbines,
and it's out of the scope of this video
but I'll give you a little bit of a clue
of how these things are connected.
We know that things
they're made up of atoms
which are made up of particles
like electrons and protons,
which are charged and
we know that a current,
an electric current is
based on the movement
of charged particles,
that when something is not magnetic,
say a non-magnetic piece of magnetite,
all of those charges are
moving more chaotically,
but if something happens to it,
maybe a lightning strike,
it can align how they
move so that they act
in concert to have a more
coherent magnetic field.
So leave I'll there I'm
already getting a little bit,
ahead of our skis so to speak,
but I do think it's really
interesting to appreciate
how all of these puzzle pieces that we see
in nature, fit together.